all right if you had to go like go down
a standard deviation IQ
but you get a perfect body for the rest
of your life would you do it
oh that's yes like whatever your dream
like whatever your dream body is you get
it like Frozen in Time the rest of your
life if I did an IQ thing I 100 would do
it I'm a smart ass [__] no you would
have to go down you're Dumber now oh
[__] no [__] that okay oh okay so you'd
keep the IQ what would you do
um
I want somebody else to go next no no
come on it's all right be honest you
know what to be honest I know what it's
like to have brains because I have it
now so I'm going to already have I'm
going to go with the brains okay you'll
keep the brains what about you you know
I think I'd keep the brains too because
hopefully I'm smart enough to make
enough money to buy my body
okay what about you
um
[Laughter]
so I don't care to have my brain so I
guess I'll go down and keep my body
looking good all right when you get a
smarter guy you know what I mean
I mean or you know
I'll do the body that's fine I am so
annoyed by stupid people I would never
want to be one of them I need to be able
to carry a conversation but it doesn't
mean you're stupid just go down a little
bit right I don't know yeah
like like a couple IQ points but you get
this perfect body so you didn't say that
in the beginning
[Music]
right now I'm like at the top of the
cream of the crop so if I was to drop a
few I'd still be at the bottom layer of
cream yeah
[Laughter]
amazing little thing with like losing
weight and like you could do it on your
own girl don't leave
60. not not the boobs like you can't get
big boobs out of nothing nobody a what I
said body no I I know when I lost it
but you said you could do it on your own
I'm saying unless you want to put like a
foreign object in your body which you
know or like about magic here foreign
no they're they they've actually come a
long way so I have like uh I have
gummies so it's like if if it pops it
doesn't leech but then it's like every
20 years all the women come forward and
they're like oh [__] I have I think that
was the old silicone yeah
but they just invent something new and
then 20 years later chicks have the same
problem it's gonna do cyborgs and I AI
robots they're going to be robots yeah
okay what about you perfect body you
gotta be Dumber I'm definitely taking
brains immediately because I'm always at
work like damn if I was so smart to just
figure out how to AI
yeah but but it's like we get the
perfect body but we're not gonna get
harder I mean me being smaller me being
larger I've lived both lives and I get
attention regardless I have always been
able to attract all different types
everything so none of that matters to me
physicalness is just so surface level
but for me if I have the brains to make
as much money as I want I mean because I
trade I do options I do Forex so for me
like if I had the brains truly to see
things on a different perspective I
would but then but then it's like if if
we were like the ultimate hotties then
you could just get a super smart guy
you know and then you wouldn't have to
think at all you could just be at home
chilling I don't want to get bullied
okay wait a minute wait a minute I I
have that option now so so it doesn't
really lead me more to it's like oh the
perfect body first of all just having
that man who is that man who takes care
of me I already have that so it does it
make me feel like oh I got to get this
perfect body so I can get the man that's
already gonna take care of me but what
about like keeping the man you got what
about it I got him well I'm saying like
wouldn't it I mean are you married you
said you're in a relationship in a
relationship right so it's like maybe
the perfect body he's like ring right
here no no I don't think so I think it
has to do with you I want to go back
yeah we're just talking about you said
something about uh what did she just say
I lost my train she said she can attract
anybody big or small anyway and that she
wants to be able to create Ai and all
types of stuff at work so she doesn't
want to lose her brains okay yeah I
can't I lost train of thought we were my
bad you made him a perfect body just so
I can look in the mirror and be like
damn [__] it's [__] fine yeah not so
I can catch a man or yeah
my girlfriend I wonder why this is like
got reaction of us women whenever it's
like we have with this you could have
this for a man it's so interesting
because we'll always have to say no no
no it's for myself but it's really
interesting because a family is supposed
to be selfless
families only work if we're selfless and
we're thinking about the other person
yeah and well and the husband and it's
interesting too because we'll give up
stuff for our kids and we'll do stuff
for the kids but it's like why why is it
a bad thing to say I want to have a
perfect body for the man
I think in like the whole like feminist
like movement of being like an
independent woman and even saying that
you're codependent on somebody it almost
is a negative tone these days but it's
not I mean technically you are you're in
a relationship it's okay to be
codependent on each other yeah like I I
would love a perfect body to get married
and then husband and then that's his
body like I think that'd be great like
what's wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with that's just how you view it
you know what I mean I think everybody
has to live with what they would feel
comfortable with so if she doesn't feel
comfortable with having a perfect body
but she feels comfortable with having a
perfect brains that's her mindset now
and what she'll live with right and
there's nothing wrong with that but I'm
just more asking like why do we have
this gut reaction that anything we do
like for the men we have like whenever
girls say oh I don't put on makeup for
the men I do it for myself I don't do
this for the men like why is our gut
reaction as women like this is for
ourselves when if we want to be in a
long-term marriage you're supposed to do
a lot at least for him
guy grows a beard because his wife wants
him to is that equivalent to what you're
saying no because I think men and women
are different and I think women are here
to serve they have an exception that we
don't yeah because I think we're lied to
and saying that we're equal and I think
the natural order of the world is we're
not I think everybody should be living
for themselves in their own happiness
and that you should never be codependent
on your partner okay I
so these people talk about being
independent independent means you're
alone yeah you're not independent and
the relationship
I'm a provider protector my
responsibility is the king of the house
is to provide and protect for her not
controller right you brought something
up but like treat you bad there's always
there's always these exceptions I was in
a toxic relationship everybody's been in
bad relationships but my duty and
responsibility and honor is to serve her
and and provide and protect for her
responsibility she takes care of the
home she cooks the food this is how we
live our life now when you say that if I
say I'm independent well then why am I
in a relationship right I rely on her to
take care of the home that's what she
does I didn't say independent did I no
but I'm saying you said codependency is
bad it's not codependent like you're
unable to like you can't survive it's
just being a team well no no no so this
is the other misconception a
relationship is not a partnership a
partnership is where you go into
business with somebody we're not in a
partnership we're in a relationship
but definitely it's not this is this is
where the problems come in we come in
it's 50 50. no it's not 50 50. I agree
with that I lead the home but here we
are right here we are so I believe it's
50 50. but this new generation set of
men is why a lot of the women are the
way they are with the feelings of
wanting to be so independent because the
men are like so aggressive men are the
new [__] let me tell you why women
ask them to be [__] and 80 of the
single parent homes are women and
they're trying to raise these boys and
they're raising them as feminine men you
need to do this you need to do this your
grandma your great grandmother's like
you go go out and find yourself a good
man that can take care of you a lot not
and when I say this a lot of the a lot a
lot of these women nowadays their mamas
are like you don't need a man you can be
an independent boss [__] and then what
happens is you you become 50 60 years
old drinking box wine watching Netflix
with your with your cats talking about
angel numbers and horoscopes I'm fine
but let me tell you something I'm fine
I'm fine and then you come 60 you're
like when am I going to do for work you
can't retire you don't also have two
three million dollars if they picked the
perfect body at 60.
yeah there you go there you go I'm not
coming at you I'm just thinking what
what as a man of a high value man we're
looking we're like I I talked I had a
conversation last night I talked to
hundreds and hundreds of women I coach
men and women I get these challenges
I've helped marriages now I'm not
perfect
I don't know everything but I'm rarely
endowed because this is what I do and I
see the challenges that some of the
ladies and men have and a lot of these
men are simping I get it they're simping
and they'll come up like like Pearl
Pearl is in a situation watch this Pearl
was in a situation A guy watched my
podcast Pearl was on there he reached
out to her somehow shaped way or form
and he wanted to date her and like as
soon as he met her he goes I want to
marry you it turned her off he was
simping am I right yeah yeah I did
and these guys I said men stop chasing
women
stop chasing women what value does a
woman bring to the table I say that
order the relationship outside of sex
what do you bring to the relationship
outside of sex I'm [__] hilarious
do men don't want to date comedians they
want to date models what
what you're you're not that I also have
a girlfriend
yeah I understand well they're right
you're in a different relationship
you're in a different relationship yeah
but but you know for men it's like
they're not looking for funny chicks
otherwise you wouldn't see all these
comedians they're always single no
that's not true have you seen that Asian
comedian she just came out with a movie
you know she was pregnant she already
had that baby I guess you know what's so
funny it's like you have to bring up the
exception whose name you don't I don't
really watch comedians well yeah but
like just I can't remember your name
handlers buy or sell all the big name
comedians are by them that woman is paid
I still do think like as much as you can
be as black and white with stuff I still
think that men do choose you or fall in
love with you
because of your personality and because
of things that you bring to other things
that you bring together when you're not
around not because you're fine
really nice bodies at that really nice
body is tatted up gorgeous I mean the
the woman that all the men walk in the
room and want and they still get cheated
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible